and no 1s cargo is an appetizer of land
snails traditional prepared and garlic
butter look at this little turd of a
fool this is like a classic thing you
thought that was gross when you were a
kid I haven't had this since I was a
baby I've never had escargot get it you
grew up with money there's a WIPO food
oh the fancy stuff oh yeah this is the
first time I've ever had this it's like
buttery and salty it's like pop chewy as
garlicky it's like a aphrodisiac we
might end up having sex after this whole
thing in your mouth I'm doing meat
bubble gum I like it really like it you
know you like it
you know you feel fancy as hell sad
why am I so grossed out by snails it's
like I eat clams and mussels which are
basically with snails of the sea we like
evicted it it tastes delicious though
but it the texture grossed me out
you Victor they're an entire mouth black
pudding is a type of blood sausage made
of congealed pork blood and oatmeal
filler Oh cookies it's like you put your
hand for goods in the dryer and forgot
about it and this trunk too small I
think it's blood sausage
there's blood in it what I know what
that means I hope it's not like a Blood
Diamond period sex look about it's like
a scab these are basically just giant
pink scabs I'm grossed out in theory but
every time I you did so good man blood
is delicious
oh I need to eat the blood of the pig
I'm a vampire Europe is like mostly
vampires right black pudding oh it's
like the darkest of chocolates
nope it's pig's blood and oatmeal this
version of haggis is served in a puff
pastry but it's historically encased in
the stomach of a sheep the inside is a
savory pudding with ingredients
including the sheep's heart lungs and
liver Oh looks good as hell is this
shepherd's pie I'm gonna guess just that
pump smell but it's beef the meat on the
inside is is
what the [ __ ] is it try it it's really
great well it tastes like I get like
four days old taste regurgitated to me
oh-ho-oh it sheeps pluck and like taste
good and you're like it's a sheep's
heart never mind
it doesn't taste good it does taste like
a liver and I can't stand liver it
actually kind of feel powerful like I'm
eating the heart of another animal sort
of inside the boiled sheeps stomach so
what like you just don't give no cuts
about sheep it'd be like if I like took
out all your insides and then like
ground it up and then like served it on
a like au platter I've never put
anything out in my life for Scotland
what the haggis is hazardous lutefisk is
a gelatinous dried cod fish that has
been treated with lye lye is a caustic
industrial chemical that aside from
curing food is commonly used in drained
ich lagers oven cleaners soap and for
decomposing flesh it sits like jello II
it's like soap that's finished like if I
didn't take a shower for three weeks
this would be the same thing this one's
like a straight whale vagina so Moshe
and blobby oh I thought I was cultured
but this is nasty I almost threw up why
[Music]
I hate how it feels in my mouth yeah
what is this that is fish cured with lye
what's lie what this is why like very
toxic
oh girl and good to see Han wait hold on
lord knows I need to know get aget again
you have the best medical system in the
world and you eat this yeah great this
is the weirdest texture that's ever been
inside my mouth I think the texture is
disgusting that I don't work I don't but
the flavor is fine go on eat what you
want to eat and I'll if you serve this
to me and I'm at your house I will eat
it I will have
even this I once ran a snail over with
my car when I was 16 you ran over a big
snail on purpose that was a really
angsty teen I wanted to know what death
felt like under my tires I'm judge don't
judge everyone's done it